so the other day my friend asked me for
a favor
no I'm exaggerating but she did kind of
ask me something that put me in a weird
position and on one hand you want to be
a good friend
I'll get the acid but then again and it
kind of made me wonder like how far are
we willing to go for someone that we
love and how far should we go especially
when it compromises your own values if
anyone asked all you have to do is push
it down the stairs I'll take care of the
rest because when someone asks you to do
something that's what I like reaches
your own moral code it's a lose-lose
situation because if you do help them
you're under arrest for accessory to the
murder of yourself and if you don't
oh nothing personal
I just gotta cover my tracks and I don't
know about you but I'm not very good at
telling people no so of course I said
okay okay do it I tell you but then I'd
have to kill you
it's not how far are you willing to go
for your friends and family and what's
like the most absurd thing you've been
asked to do I don't know if you can tell
but I haven't missed the line now I got
it like two days ago and I've had braces
before I had braces for like four years
back in the day but my teeth have
started shifting and now I have to wear
Invisalign for like a year or two and so
it's like getting used to things then
your teeth all over again and but
hopefully it will be it'll be more I
don't know subdued next Monday I just
get used to it I guess
hopefully I will see you then stay
awesome Gotham
or should I should or should I shake -
and cashew I'm mentally plan out how I'm
gonna react if someone tries to jump me
I'm a rapist